wo ist dein ding
lisa ja kein problem ich habe noch genug
deutsch übungen die ich machen kann
ich freue mich aber schon wenn du
wiederkommst ist dann der urlaub habt
ihr tolles wetter tolle das klingt super
das wetter bei mir
ich glaube es um die 7 grad und es
bewölkt abend soll es vielleicht noch
regnen und morgen wird es noch kälter
der himmel ist einfach immer grauer ihr
habt sonne und 20 grad war das ist so
gemein zu lisa nico von der party der
bei euch gewohnt hat der doch seine
tasche verloren was hat nikon radio
gesagt wie die tasche aus sieht schwarz
und ein aufnäher mit einem fahrrad
wieso naja ich glaube ich habe sie
gefunden